and I want to get the read from 2020
Democratic presidential candidate Tulsi
Gabbard thanks for joining us the this
news is coming quickly from all all
areas first of all bill de blasio made
some comments about running low on food
families needing to survive and pinpoint
it back to the federal federal
government saying that's where it has to
come from that's the most important area
and he must move immediately I think
everyone agrees on that and still yes it
feels like there's a lot of a lot of
stalling there a lot of the old
political shenanigans that this this
continues to be a problem unfortunately
where partisanship is getting in the way
of just delivering what the American
people need right now especially as our
country faces this crisis now is not the
time for politics now is the time for
leaders to step up stand together we are
all in this together and to put the
health and well-being of the American
people above all else I think it's a
little bit encouraging today that you
know I came in expecting that we were
gonna have votes at 10 o'clock this
morning on an a direct aid package
directed towards working people every
day Americans across the country but
there was concern coming from
Republicans it was not crafted in a
bipartisan way and so that vote never
happened and and literally both sides
are coming together I think they're
working with the administration on
making sure that what we pass in
Congress is something that both
Democrats and Republicans have worked on
to get through the Senate and get on to
the President's desk as quickly as
possible and I think that's the most
important point I did see where minuchin
and Nancy Pelosi have had several
conversations today you know the idea of
the same usual a big wish list from one
side and a big wish list from the other
and all this rain delaying there's no
time for that the window was carrying
and there seems to be a little hanging
fruit and who we want to help I think
everyone would agree paid sick leave
folks out there in the gig economy
people without health insurance
I mean it's some pretty simple stuff but
what about something bolder and bigger
that President Trump is talking about
the payroll tax cut this was something
Democrats really seem to embrace from
President Obama was in office it's
something that helps small business
employers and employees and it's huge
it's big it would be impacted
I think overall when we look about look
at the struggles that small-business
owners especially have and just trying
to keep their doors open and keep people
employed I think that's a very good
debate that we need to have and I think
there's a lot of value in that I think
where I am looking as this immediate
short-term impact and that's where I
differ a little bit I don't think that
this payroll tax credit will do enough
to help those for example who make less
than $25,000 a year they won't see much
of a help coming from that as you
mentioned those who are uber drivers
that's where they get their income from
or who are working on the gig economy
freelancers those individuals won't get
assistance from that payroll tax credit
what I'm proposing is an immediate
emergency temporary universal basic
payment that goes directly to every
adult American in this country to help
them in this dire situation where most
Americans in this country their work and
paycheck to paycheck struggling just to
get by and don't even have a buffer to
think about how do you buy two weeks of
food supplies for your family and the
other considerations less than 30
seconds because of all the breaking news
and I appreciate you staying so how much
would it be and when you say all
Americans does not means tested everyone
will get a check how much would that
check be I'm proposing $1,000 I think
that can be negotiated but again this is
a time of crisis we've been spending
four billion dollars a month in
Afghanistan with a lot of people
wondering what is this for how is this
helping the American people we need to
put the well-being of the American
people first right now and invest in
them the idea that this has to be big
what we've seen in Japan is now they've
gone twice with stimulus Italy working
on their third package I think the
American public is giving you license to
go huge go as big as possible the first
time so it's not you're not chasing the
epidemic is that possible it is possible
we have to make it happen I want to make
one note the thing that has not yet been
done that we've seen successful in
countries like South Korea
is mass testing free testing red tape to
go through we've got to get people
tested we got you down for $1,000 for
every American thank you very much folks
more right after you